Jerry God gross
oh Jerry guys
oh god oh I think he might be having a
heart attack what what are you serious
oh so much stuff is happening right now
call 9-1-1 okay just breathe okay you're
gonna be fine no geez did a dinosaur
just fart Jerry get a grip sorry guys
God apology not accepted stop talking
[ __ ] I wish I could stop smelling dude
seriously Jerry did you eat farts for
lunch Tom Gary's having a heart attack
oh no I didn't know that Jerry you okay
okay I got you some magazines and those
boring word jumbles you like to do is
there anything else you need Jay maybe
some Gas-X haha Tom how is Ian give it
to me straight he's great he should be
out of here in a day or two doctor
medically speaking how would you
describe what happened to Jerry you had
a mild heart attack
yeah but he also exhibited excessive
flatulence is there a term for having a
heart attack while releasing so much gas
not really gastrointestinal distress is
common during a cardiac event I just
want to hear the doctor say that Jerry
had a fart attack is that too much to
ask so while they repaint the lines in
the parking lot we're asking everyone to
do street parking I'm not street parking
my Mercedes well everyone is I'm doing
it because nobody wants to steal a
Saturn
all right uh moving on to recycling
you okay Ron just a little tooth pain
I'm fine continue okay each department
will be getting blue bins
do you need to go to the dentist Ron I
don't like dentists just a second
hey no no no no no no no no no no
[Applause]
no no no no no no no no no no
[Applause]
oh my God I'm sorry everybody what were
we talking about recycling dentist
pulled the tooth out yesterday
but it's always a good idea to
demonstrate to your co-workers that you
are capable of withstanding a tremendous
amount of pain
plus it's always fun to see Tom faint
I'm sorry was your name Jennifer no it's
Jennifer with two y's I used to be
Jennifer but then I decided to Rebrand
myself
oh wait hang on it's Annex o'clock
um
well nice to meet you my name's April
and I just wanted to say that your dress
is so cute it's Bonks I saw my spinning
instructor wearing it and I was like
shut up where do I get that oh my God
who's your spinning instructor Gregory
or Winona I go to Giannis who are
Gregory and Winona I've never heard of
them before are they better Winona rocks
my world seriously you need to get me in
there like that's a must must must she's
the worst person I've ever met
I want to travel the world with her you
have to like text me I will sorry for
the delay ladies I was busy being
ambushed by treachery so did you have a
chance to compare notes on your
respective duties totally tinny and I
have been like totally bonding we've
just been like blah blah blah blah blah
blah blah like talking like so much
forever it's all so delicious I know
right it's like The Best Day Ever I know
I'm eating it all up wow it's nice to
see a friendship blossoming instead of
wilting away like a dying turd flower
totes um we also came up with these
nicknames for each other
[ __ ] and skank how crazy amazing is that
last well you know what I think is crazy
amazing commitment I'm looking for
someone who's in it for the long haul we
are basically creating a new version of
Pawnee and if Pawnee is going to commit
to one of you you need to commit to
Pawnee Jennifer do you have kids ew no
I've had so much Rejuvenation that I
don't think a baby could get out of
there if it tried you know it
can I just say something I'm having so
much fun right now oh my God me too like
so much fun can I just say something
though yeah okay you don't want this job
seriously this place is the pits it's
like if you worked here you'd be like
Ugh and Leslie would be like blah blah
blah and he'd be like uh okay can I say
something right now I totally think that
you're right and I had been thinking
about going someplace warm while my
husband is in jail oh my God can I just
say something yes okay you should
totally stay in my house in Miami what
I'm serious come by anytime just let
yourself in the gate kind of jams
sometimes but you can just jump it you
are so amazing right now you're like
skinny Mother Teresa
it's Dwyane Wade's house
I got his address off the internet
I really hope he's there when she walks
in and he throws a basketball at her
head I probably should have said no to
some of his ideas but he's on his way
here right now here he is just be cool
hey guys what's up
um oh I just remembered can I show you
something out to the front area and
leave your cell phones uh because of no
reason just leave anything that can't
get wet actually like you would normally
that's
okay here we go to the parking lot now
wow this is really sad
yep follow to me guys just go into the
parking lot for normal government
reasons
sorry I can't go through with this I was
gonna pull a prank
no yeah I've hired these guys in ski
masks to kidnap us and I was gonna
pretend to be a hero they were gonna
shoot me and drive the van into the
river and that's when the divers would
go in pull you guys out of the water and
I would be standing on the shore like
hey get pranked much what the I even got
these squibs from a special effects guy
and I was gonna say this code word and
that's when I would push this button no
no
foreign
all over me
thank you
I mean it
Ben that was amazing right best prank
ever
my keys looks like it's open really
we've been telling that kid for a couple
hours
I mean it must have been somebody else
it was packitis
that doesn't mean anything to me this is
a peach pit
okay he was eating a peach when I went
to go talk to him this is his Ace of
Spades
but he leaves all his victims and it's
still warm okay go and arrest him and
send us to the lab we don't
we don't the lab okay this isn't
strictly legal we could talk to him for
maybe an hour and then I got to let him
go you talk to him first you have a
scary face hey no in a good way
scary cute yeah go talk to him okay
I didn't do this man I promise no son
I'm a police officer okay you shouldn't
lie to me I'm not I've never been here
before and why would I do this because
you've had run-ins with Miss nope in the
past
just a second
yeah ask him about the peach pit
this isn't one-way glass you know I can
see you
you know I like nope
I screw with her because she gets all
riled up and her face gets all scrunched
up like this
but I like her
she's all right
you see
what statue's fine
crappy halloweeners that's hilarious
where's the kid in the conference room
trying to hide his obvious guilt Leslie
I don't know what to tell you I don't I
don't think he did it yeah he did and we
need a confession
okay Andy and I are going to take a walk
and it's going to be just you buckitis
and these pliers
look I'm not going to torture this kid
nobody said torture
why don't you let me take a run Adam
boss
in order to think like one of these guys
you have to think like them
yeah he's never seen you before so imply
that you're someone very important and
that you can make his life hell
would you like some boiling hot coffee
your face
Burt Macklin I'm with the FBI for my
next prank I'm going to build a hospital
in a poor part of China who'll never see
it coming
[Music]